charles
happy birthday to you
yeah
all right
i hope it's everything that you wanted
love aniga
well what are you waiting for
adibosoft 3d printer
instructions
set up in a spacious area
do not attempt to fix or modify the
printer in any way
hey anika
where's trolls at
i don't know
he said he didn't feel like coming
you guys feeling ready yeah yeah
warning
use extreme caution when printing any
personal photos
the printer is designed to permanently
shut down in an attempt to print any
life form oh wow
charles is gonna wish he was here to see
this
okay let's take a picture
warning
your use of the printer will be
monitored
do not produce any illegal drugs weapons
or counterfeits
hey charles
did you forget about our movie
beta testers have reported print
sickness
an unhealthy obsession using the printer
i haven't seen him i haven't seen either
of them
print sickness is dangerous
quarters are in place for a reason
if you experience any symptoms of print
sickness stop printing immediately
hello
it's me
just about to call you
wow
that's an expensive suit
did you imprint this there's someone i'd
like you to meet
what wait what
what is this
i thought it was impossible to print
humans not nearly
the feature was deliberately removed
from retail
all it did was a few
modifications of my own
but you already have me
why do you need another copy you were
almost perfect
you really were
but then i started seeing all your flaws
nobody's
perfect besides she's just a carbon copy
of you
wrong a little tweak to the metadata is
all it took a little younger
more exciting
more refined taste
of course
there can only be one of you in this
you're
world
you'll never get away with this
they'll find me
no
they'll have no reason to look for you
so
so
you